in the wake of the novel coronavirus the
Port of Los Angeles expects goods from
international shippers especially China
to stay below average to at least the
first quarter of 2020 but a slow
recovery could begin as early as May and
if so that's some very welcome news as
the US prepares to hunker down for an
extended period the biggest and worst
point loss ever for the down the port is
the biggest entry point for Chinese
goods to the US and handles more
container cargo than any US seaport last
year alone the port facilitated a
massive 276 billion dollars of trade
it's kept close tabs on Chinese economic
activity since the kovat 19 strain of
coronavirus began to spread quickly in
late 2019 in February imports at the
facility plunged 22.5% while exports
fell 5.7 percent this decrease came on
top of a slump that ran throughout the
fourth quarter as a result of the trump
administration's aggressive tariffs on
Chinese goods coming into the u.s.
output from China's factories hammered
for weeks by the public health crisis
investment and consumer spending have
all declined still the country has had
some success in reducing new cases of
Cova 19 and the government said it
expects to be fully functional by June
as the number of confirmed cases
continues to climb in the u.s. many
consumers have reacted by panic buying
toilet paper paper towels hand sanitizer
in bottled water but those are goods
that for the most part aren't shipped
from other countries to Port of Los
Angeles typically brings in things like
clothing electronics furniture all of
which are coming in at lower volumes
right now the port's executive director
gene seroka
is hopeful that by August or September
things at the port will be back to
normal assuming China continues to
recover and the US can slow or stop the
spread of copán 19
even a small recovery in the shipment of
important goods from much-needed
pharmaceutical and chemical products to
auto parts and iPhones
it's an indication that at least some
things can remain stable ahead of a full
economic rebound